all right we're still on ideas that we
introduced
on friday and you might be able to see
some clues over there on the right-hand
side
when we say two things uh leading to
each other
right that you get one from the other
what do we call those two statements
starting with an e
you could go back to your notes if you
needed it's there in the book
it's eq let me give you a clue there
there e well we we sometimes say equal
when we talk about numbers
but we we mean equivalent uh when we're
talking about
logical statements right so we talked
about equivalent statements
now let's unpack this a little more what
we mean by equivalent statements
is that there is implication in both
directions
does that make sense you know if um if
2x
equals 4 2x
equals 4. there's a statement right
it's an equivalent statement
with x equals 2. do you agree if one of
them is true it implies the other but it
goes in the other direction also
right by the way this this second thing
here
looking at it backwards right and we
have a name for this you've actually
learned this
before but not in this context when you
say statement but backwards we call this
the converse right please note saying a
statement backwards
as opposed to saying the opposite of the
statement those are quite different
aren't they
sometimes a converse is true but
sometimes it's not
so the way we say this because you know
mathematicians famously lazy
why says two statements well you can say
one you've got
p and q both leading up to each other
so what we do is we put in a
double-sided arrow
in there right that double-sided arrow
means the implication runs in both
directions
these are equivalent statements okay
which i've put over there on the
left-hand side
i've already kind of read a bit of this
out this can be read as p and q
uh you could say equivalent statements
or you could say logically equivalent
both of those would be fine
and then comes in something which
might seem like it comes a bit out of
left field but it is a really important
connective piece of tissue right another
way we can read this
is that p is true
if and only if
q is true right these are necessary and
sufficient in both directions okay now
just like we saw before
mathematicians love to make things nice
and concise and they're like if and only
if
anybody got time to write that so what
do they do instead they
abbreviate this into and if
with two fs i kid you not that's the
abbreviation and the way you read it out
is
if and only if okay you're gonna get
quite used to seeing it i guess
people are sick of writing this uh four
words over and over again
okay um now question for you
uh my example statement p is that it's 3
pm my example statement q
is that the bell will ring are p and q
equivalent statements
in this example
they are not p
is equivalent to q that's false
but why why is it false
let's just even think monday to friday
right forget about weekends
p and q are not equivalent statements
can anyone argue for me why can anyone
provide me some substantiation
friends
very good okay fantastic so the issue
here is and i wonder if you were going
in the same place ju right
um the bell let's actually get this
logic down the bell rings at other times
so what that means is very good um it is
not necessarily true that it's 3 p.m
if you hear the bell ring it's like oh
the bell rings is it 3 p.m
if only right it may be 206 or maybe 12
33 or
maybe and on no no right so that's why
you can see here q
that that doesn't imply p just because
the bell is ringing that doesn't imply
it's 3pm it could be any of those other
times make sense
okay excellent last big idea we
introduced
last week starts with a queue and you
remember has to do with amounts
sizes quantifiers thank you very much
quantifiers now
last time we just talked about
quantifiers as things that give you
quantities but now i'm going to
introduce
uh some symbols that we will use in
place of words when it's sometimes handy
right so sometimes you mean something's
true no matter what value you put in
right if something is always true no
matter what value you put in we would
say that's
for all values of you know n
x t whatever this statement's always
true
now because the key operating word is
all or
always we use an a but
a's get used for a lot in maths right so
i don't know who thought of this but we
take an a
and we turn it upside down right so when
you see an upside down a
and i'll give you an example of this in
a second right the way you read it is
for all values of and then you complete
the sentence
so let me give you an example of one
right for
all values of n
where n is an integer
then 2n will be even
make sense shall i come to your question
for a second if n is an integer
you know negative 1 1 2 3 4 etc 2 n is
going to be an even number
right every value of n it works okay
question do you guys put a vertical bar
before the belong to symbol
you're talking about here yeah between
in here
generally not generally not you will
sometimes see that but you don't
have to i learned that the
[Music]
the vertical bar you'll see this come up
a little bit later on one of the tricky
things of the vertical bar is
actually a little bit like our wavy
symbol has more than one meaning
one of them is this but in fact i think
what you'll find more
frequently is you'll see this there's no
vertical bar
it doesn't if i'm just going to read it
for all values of n
that belong to or are an element of the
integer number set
2n will be even okay all right
uh can i move to the next quantifier
what was the other one
sometimes sometimes instead of always
something is true so sometimes
a statement can be true even if it's not
always right now there's some fancy
language for this right
the way we would say this in
mathematical terminology is
even if it's not for all values there
exists a value
somewhere out there in the universe
where this statement is true
there exists a value
somewhere where this is true okay now
because the operating word is exists
right
we would like to use an e a capital e
just like a capital a
just one teeny problem if you take a
capital a and turn it upside down you
get this
if you take a capital e and turn it
upside down you get
a capital e so what do we do instead
we take that capital e and we just turn
it around the
other way uh
yeah look they're not the best but
that's just what we landed with okay
so when you see this backwards e it
means there exists a value for instance
there exists a value of n
where n is an integer
such that 3n is divisible by 5. this
isn't always true obviously right
3 6 9 12. these are some of the three
n's out there they're not divisible by 5
but there does exist a value in fact
there are a bunch of values in fact
there are infinitely many
such the 3n will be divisible by 5. 15
is fine
30 is fine 45's fine and so on and so on
you okay with that